il ne faut plus qu'une semaine pour
obtenir son passeport ne viendront pas
levé adopté j'imagine l es2 à es10 les
tranchantes et
oui on a une chance folle on sait ce
qu'on fait tu crois ce qu'on sait pas
encore on découvrira je vous admire
monde est bien meilleur grâce à des gens
comme salut salut vraiment partout ni
même le chéri stephen j'allais pas la
nina mais n'a écouté sur ma fille était
dans sa chambre est aussi avez vous des
photos nues quand j'ai cherché sa photo
de profil sur le site internet des
lipides site combien ce que vous a coûté
cette adoption sa centenaire cette
arnaque s'appelle une réclamation
les escrocs font danseurs de soutirer le
maximum d'argent
enfant elle donne de nouvelles victimes
et où est votre mari il est parti sans
laisse on ne fait pas justice soi même
il disait qu'il pouvait s'en charger
alors j'ai dit tu as tu es notre fille
sur le marché noir devait on était si
près du but qu'est ce que tu voulais que
je place communiqué
contre le mur d'habitude on prend juste
la fin mais la nécessité nous rassemble
il faut leur taper ce qu'il ce n'est que
de l'argent c'est toute manière nous tu
fais ce que tu veux
je vais me sortir d'ici
on a un problème
à quoi tient le coup chéri